so the the cameo thing oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah
let's talk about that and let's talk
about big brother too yeah yeah
i thought man that was the most obvious
[ __ ] ever because here's the
thing about
cameo i got a lot of cameos in there and
a lot of them are like you know stupid
and i won't do them
some you know i go i'll do this one i'll
do it completely straight this person
for those that don't know they uh asked
um if i would break up
with their grad school boyfriend yeah
now we all know all those sugar a grad
school fans out there right yeah
so immediately i was like oh this is
[ __ ] and who would have
me break up with their girlfriend or
boyfriend during during
exam week whatever it was so i go you
know i'm gonna do this i'm gonna do it
straight
and i'll make it build it man i'll make
my little five dollars or whatever i
make it cameo
125.
discount code
twenty-five percent off at the time uh
and so i uh
i did a shitty straight yeah hey you
know uh and cody i'm really sorry
cheyenne where the whole name was
and uh i wish you the best hey maybe so
and i went on for like three minutes by
the way yeah and i go
maybe someday we can all high five at a
sugar ray show a backstage i i go okay
that's certainly tipped off and then i
just so funny and then i just kind of
let it go and i go
oh the three or four people who see that
i'll get a laugh that they got over on
me and that's it
fast forward it's true again trending
i look at people on social media can't
keep telling me i'm not famous and i've
trended twice
in the last month number one
you know what i'm saying so yeah [ __ ]
viral king yo
[ __ ] valtrex gang right here you are
good at it like yeah
well well i am i good at it when i'm not
trying to do it
dude do you know what i'm saying i think
that is being like just speaking
it's a talent i don't know it's just
being such a [ __ ] idiot people are
like is he that [ __ ] stupid
so that's kind of how we got here i
gotta talk to you guys because i go
man i love you guys i'm big fans and
like i can't believe you guys didn't see
that no dude i i completely but a lot of
people didn't we
we couldn't tell yeah i had no idea you
nailed it dude you really did it
like that well but what made me feel bad
is people like oh what a sweet guy
such a nice guy and so i had to like
kind of back off the little narrative
now i'm like well people are thinking
what a great guy i am such a nice thing
to do for someone that's been very
difficult so
i was caught in this conundrum of like
no i didn't mean to believe
it but it was like it was really weird
but they well for my holiday cameo
numbers
but again you guys are not getting it
you guys are so that's so funny yeah
i watched it and i go i'm like here we
go again
cody we got another one from homie cause
the thing is i've done those ones too
people will ask me to break up with
someone as well and
and you know and i do them like because
i don't know if they're joking or not
yeah i've done them too yeah i've done
them too and i just do them straight or
you know but i
i that one i could tell yeah because
when you you go like
sugar a grad school fan you know how
many 25 year old grad school
they're not you know what i mean that
that was their music that was their
couples
i understand them being ironic urban
outfit or sugar a nostalgia fans i get
it but not like
you know you're our mumford and sons bro
yeah yeah yeah
that didn't ring true to me so well they
they booked i there was an article about
it afterwards and they apparently booked
like four or five
other people to to do that same yeah we
got scaramucci to do it
okay yeah anthony scaramucci and i
believe that dude from uh
pod did it okay the poor guy who like
started it was trying to get some like
social media hype and like
people were just leaving the dots like
but i did it i did the whole thing and
people like well we're not interested
that you did the joke
words of the people that got fooled you
know that was kind of sad so shout out
to dude
that is so funny that is so funny he's
like that's my [ __ ]
what the heck come on i'm the curator
here he was
how do i monetize i made the playlist
shut up nerd shut up we don't care
everybody cares
just play fly again we don't [ __ ]
care dude
[ __ ] dweeb but it's my playlist get
out of the party man
we don't care oh man